- She's no stranger to
blockbusters herself.
You've seen her in dozens over
the years from "Halloween"
to my personal favorite, "Knives Out."
Her new podcast, "Letters
From Camp," is out now.
Let's dial in with
Jamie Lee Curtis, y'all.
(audience applauds)
(gentle jazz music)
Hi! Oh, wait, there she is.
- Hi.
- Oh, hi. Oh, my gosh.
Your whole look is so cool.
- Oh, I'm right here.
- Yes, can you hear me?
- I can, what do you mean?
What is so cool? You're cool.
- No, your whole vibe. I
love your glasses, the hair.
Your whole vibe is so cool.
- Well, I'm an old woman.
We wear glasses.
- Whatever, you look rock
and roll right now, I would love that.
So wait, are you getting
used to all this Skyping
and Zooming we do now?
I had never even heard
of Zoom before this.
- And neither had I.
And the truth of the matter
is that I'm a technical girl.
I can work my way around some
sort of technology, lighting.
Obviously, I'm a photographer,
so I know kind of where to put the light.
But the truth of the matter is my husband
and I had never done any
sort of Zoom or FaceTime.
The word FaceTime to me, always
like, oh, FaceTime? Go away.
I don't wanna look at.
And my daughter, Annie, and her husband...
My daughter got married.
- Oh, that's so exciting.
- And so they just had
a year's anniversary, thank you.
But they taught us how to
Zoom for the first time.
- Well, speaking of tech,
sometimes it gets
(chuckles) the better of us.
Like with your "Knives
Out" costar, Chris Evans.
What happened here?
Do you know what happened (laughs)
with that whole thing that-
- Well, I think we...
(audience laughs)
Well, that whole thing, exactly.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- I didn't know how to word it.
- Hey, I didn't say it so long as you did.
Look, I'm sweating already. (laughs)
- I know, I just was
like, was it an accident?
And then all of a sudden,
I love that he turned it
into like, now that
I've got your attention.
That was awesome.
- So my question is this, he's so smart
and such a unbelievably
beautiful human being,
I'm wondering if it was even planned.
- Oh, he's so clever.
I kinda think it was planned
just 'cause he was trying
to get people to vote, you know?
- Right.
- And he was like,
"Now that I have your attention."
- And you know... (laughs)
But you know what I mean?
I could've made some sort of joke
and say he took after his
movie father, Don Johnson,
or I could be also like...
(Kelly laughs)
'Cause I'm really, really close friends
with Melanie Griffith.
She's one of my best friends
and has been forever.
And she was married to him twice,
so.
- Twice? I didn't know that.
- Yeah.
- I guess she didn't know
the first time. (laughs)
That's awesome.
You have a new project
called My Hand In Yours.
So what is it, and what inspired it?
I think I have some stuff here.
- Yes you do. Thank you for mentioning it.
- Yeah.
- So I'm 61 years old,
and for a long time, when
anyone has ever been sad
or going through a hard time,
I will always write a note
and say at the end of
it, "My hand in yours,"
as if to say to them,
I'm not there with you,
but imagine what it would feel
like if my hand was in yours.
And then about a year ago, I
realized that I could turn it
into something to benefit
Children's Hospital Los Angeles.
And I went to a sculptor friend of mine.
And I think I saw that
you have the sculpture.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- And I asked her if she would
make a small hand sculpture
of two hands holding.
- [Kelly] It's so beautiful.
- And do you see it there?
- Yes, it's in my hand.
- Can you see it
on your thing?
Yes, it's right there.
And it fits in the palm of your hand.
And I decided to start a store.
So at 61 years old, I've started a store.
100% of all of the sales
of all of the objects,
for instance, I'm wearing
a necklace right now.
So it's a small hand pendant
on a beautiful silver chain.
- Yes.
- And there are other objects.
And all of the sale of all of these items
goes toward Children's
Hospital Los Angeles.
And all of the artists
donated all of their time.
And we are adding notebooks,
and blankets, and pillows.
And so it's a way for
people to send to loved ones
at this time where it's so,
so difficult for everyone
to feel that connection.
And particularly because of the pandemic,
which, of course, I wasn't anticipating
when I invented this whole idea.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It just happens to have
come out right at a time
when people need love and
comfort more than ever.
- Yeah, I don't believe in accidents.
- [Jamie] So that's what I mean it to be.
I think that it's a really cool thing
that it happened to come
out right in this time
when people do need it more
now than ever with connection.
But you've-
- And you can send a note with it.
And even the little medallion,
which you have there, is $12.
And again, 100% of all of the sales
goes right to Children's Hospital.
And-
- So great.
- People are responding.
And it's really heartwarming at this time
where everybody feels so
divided, so complicated,
so conflicted about so many things
that you can cross all boundaries
and reach out and give a gift to someone,
and say, I'm thinking of
you, my hand in yours,
and that I think my hand in yours
is how we're gonna heal
this country right now.
- That's so beautifully,
beautifully said.
- It's a hard time.
- Yeah.
Well, you've also been
working on a podcast
during the pandemic, so what's that about?
- I did.
So weirdly enough, this is a true story,
my goddaughter, who's now 26,
wrote me a letter from camp
when she was 12 and never sent it.
And her mother sent it
to me last November.
And it was sealed in an envelope
with that kind of 12-year-old handwriting.
And it was a 12-year-old's
letter from camp saying,
"Dear godmother, Jamie, I made a mistake.
I did something stupid."
And ultimately, what happened
is that I said to her,
"This should be a TV show or something."
And it turned out to be a
scripted podcast for Audible,
very funny, a comedy
called "Letters From Camp."
And it is a hilarious show.
It stars a young actress
named Sunny Sandler.
My godson, Jake Gyllenhaal, is in it,
Edi Patterson, Kirby
Howell-Baptiste, and yours truly.
I play the camp director, natch.
And it's really fun,
funny, and it's nostalgic.
And it was a way, again, with COVID
for kids to be able to go back to camp
because, of course, so
many kids didn't get
to go to camp this summer.
- Well, speaking of kiddos,
congrats on 35 years of marriage
with the very funny Christopher Guest.
(audience applauds)
- Six.
- Oh, really?
- 36.
I mean, but who's counting?
- Wow, I would be if it's that many.
Wait, so how did you meet?
- (laughs) All right.
I'll trying to figure out a really fast,
but it's a funny story.
So I was single.
I was looking at "Rolling Stone" magazine,
and I turned the page in 1984,
and there was a picture of three men
with their arms around
each other like dudes.
And I said to my girlfriend, Debra Hill,
"Oh, I'm gonna marry that guy."
And I pointed to the guy on
the outside of the picture.
And she said, "Oh, yeah, I tried
to put him in a movie once.
He's an actor. His name is Chris Guest."
I was like, "Oh, I'm gonna marry him."
Never seen him in my life.
- What?
- And she said,
"He's with your agency."
Never saw him. Well, I never saw him.
And so the next day, I called his agent
'cause that's what one does.
And he picked up the phone and said,
"I know all about it, Jamie. Chris Guest."
And I was like, "Ah, yeah,
I know. The guy's cute.
Here's my number. I think he's cute.
Goodbye."
And then he never called me.
and I dated somebody
else for a couple months,
and then broke up with that person.
Took that person to the airport.
Went from the airport,
picked up Melanie Griffith
and her then husband, Steve Bauer.
And we went to Hugo's in
West Hollywood. I sat down.
Two tables away was
Christopher facing me, swear.
And he looked at me and he went like this.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
And then I looked at him and did the same.
And then two minutes later, he
got up to leave or something,
and he stood there next to his
seat and he went like this.
And then I went like.
(audience laughs)
- (laughs) Hey again. (laughs)
- And then he left.
But then he called me,
mm-hmm, the next day.
That was June 28th.
He was leaving to do "Saturday Night Live"
for a year on August 8th.
He left for a year.
I was making the movie, "Perfect."
We got engaged September 13th.
And we got married
December 18 of that year.
So we knew each other four months
and had never spent more
than three days together
at a time.
- That's an insane story.
That's a movie right there.
(Jamie laughs)
And are you talking
about this magazine?
- Well, let me say this.
It's my life.
- Is the magazine
you're referring to?
- That's the, okay. Yes,
so show the picture.
- Oh, oh, I will.
- Okay.
So you're gonna find it.
- I am.
- Okay, now you're gonna
have to find it.
- No, I'll find it.
It's right here.
- It's a pic, okay there.
It's so crazy.
- [Kelly] Boom.
- That's crazy.
- Boom.
- Okay, I literally saw
the guy on the right, and I
said, "I'm gonna marry him,"
and I married him-
- I think that's so sweet.
- 36 years ago.
- I love you so much.
- You know what?
(Kelly chuckles)
And I love you.
- (laughs) All right, y'all.
For more information
about My Hand In Yours,
go to our website.
Check out Jamie's new podcast,
"Letters From Camp," as well.
And you can catch her next
year in "Halloween Kills,"
which I'm excited about.